[Musik]
ja und du wirst sieben
hätte gerne Geburtstagstorte
was für ein Thema sollen wir machen mir
fällt keins ein
Video
Pikachu ja ja
okay dann gehe ich in die Küche und leg
los
[Musik]
nein
das wird eine Überraschung
[Musik]
morgen gibt es deine Geburtstagstorte
ich habe noch eine Idee
ich wäre nicht Pummeluff wenn
dann legen wir mal los
[Musik]
liebe Familie liebes Team liebe
Zuschauer wir starten heute mit einer
neuen Operation es geht um diesen
Menschen
Ella sechs Jahre wird bald 7 und wünscht
sich eine Party eine Geburtstagsparty da
die Operation streng geheim ist nenne
ich sie
Operation
abgeschweift von der katzenparty
die ich mir sehr gewünscht habe doch die
Wünsche meines Kindes geht natürlich vor
wünscht sie sich ihr könnt schon erahnen
eine pokémon-party
okay lass die Party steigen ich möchte
euch jetzt mal ganz kurz den Ablauf
schildern einen Plan erstellen und dann
schauen wie wir diese Operation
schönstmöglich durchbekommen
die Party steigt für 10 Kids 14 bis 18
Uhr am Samstag dann teilen wir mal die
verschiedenen Gewerke auf
hängedeko ein Happy Birthday
ella
Kinder wollen auch beschäftigt sein aber
trotzdem genügend Freiraum zum Spielen
deswegen gehen wir zu den Aktivitäten
ein Pokéball Dosenwerfen wurfspielen
[Musik]
kommen wir zum wichtigsten Part hier
natürlich gibt es eine Motto Torte
da habe ich mir überlegt Waffeln am
Stiel und die Stiele pinnen wir dann an
einen Pokéball
und selbstgemachte Pizza die sich selbst
belegen können vielleicht auch wie eine
Puppe war
die Kinder bekommen natürlich nur Wasser
aber natürlich dürfen sweets nicht
fehlen
und was wäre eine erfolgreiche schöne
Party mit unvergesslichen Momenten mit
Fotobox mit Goodie Bags ohne ein
Maskottchen
[Musik]
also los geht's
jetzt geht's los mit der Pikachu Torte
ich werde jetzt dafür einen Rührkuchen
machen das ist auch ein Standardrezept
ein Basic Rezept und es lege ich euch
auch gerne separat in meinem Blog und in
meiner App an und zwar brauche ich dafür
8 Eier 400 Gramm Zucker etwas Salz
Vanilleextrakt jeweils 400 g Buttermilch
und Sonnenblumenöl 500 g Mehl plus 6
Teelöffel Backpulver oder ihr nehmt mein
backmehl 100 g gekauft und 100 g back
fester Schokoladen Drops ich backe das
ganze jetzt auch gleich in Springformen
das heißt ich habe hier schon mal zwei
kleine die sind 15 cm groß und zwei
größere die haben 20 cm Durchmesser und
damit kann ich schon mal die Grundform
von Pikachu so ein bisschen Formen damit
später eben eine schöne dreidimensionale
Torte wird aber jetzt erstmal den Teig
dafür verrühre ich jetzt die Eier mit
dem Zucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt in
etwa 5 bis 10 Minuten
dann kommen die zwei Flüssigkeiten dazu
nämlich Buttermilch und Sonnenblumenöl
die werden kurz eingerührt ihr verrührt
dann am besten schon mehl mit Backpulver
und Kakao damit alles schön Klümpchen
frei ist und dann einfach gemeinsam mit
den Schokoladen Drops einrühren
der Teig wird dann in die 4 Formen
eingefüllt und schön verteilt und dann
kommen sie schon in den vorgeheizten
Ofen bei 170 Grad ober-/unterhitze und
werden gebacken falls ihr keine zwei
Backöfen habt könnt ihr das ganze auch
bei Heißluft backen dann einfach auf
zwei Ebenen und dann könnt ihr alle vier
Kuchen gleichzeitig backen die kleineren
haben natürlich eine etwas kürzere
Backzeit und die größere eine längere
Backzeit aber das steht auch alles ganz
detailliert in meiner App
[Musik]
während die Kuchenböden jetzt im Ofen
backen könnt ihr auch gerne schon mal
die Cremefüllung zubereiten ich mache
jetzt einfach eine Ganache weil eine
Ganache wirklich schön fest wird die
Torte stabil ist und ich sie später auch
ganz toll drumherum streichen kann eine
Ganache könnt ihr entweder mit weißer
Vollmilch oder auch Zartbitterkuvertüre
zubereiten Zartbitter oder Vollmilch
wäre jetzt geschmacklich hervorragend
ich nehme jetzt aber trotzdem die weiße
schmeckt den Kindern auch ganz gut denn
die kann ich später noch einfärben und
dann habe ich einfach einen schönen
Kontrast zu den Schokoladen ich nehme
jetzt dafür die Sahne die lass dir in
einem Kochtopf kurz aufkochen und
schaltet dann den Herd ab jetzt die
weiße Kuvertüre einfach dazu rühren und
alles schön schmelzen lassen jetzt kommt
hier noch die Lebensmittel dazu ich
nehme jetzt ein schönes Pikachu gelb die
Ganache wird anschließend dann noch
umgefüllt abgedeckt und die lasst ihr
jetzt bei Raumtemperatur stehen bis sie
wirklich schön abgekühlt ist und dann
eine schöne streichfähige Konsistenz hat
sobald die Kuchenböden gebacken und
ausgekühlt sind könnt ihr sie dann auch
gerne aus den Ringen rauslösen bevor ich
sie Schneide stelle ich sie meistens
noch in den Kühlschrank damit sie
einfach schön kalt sind zum Schneiden da
geht das ganze nämlich ein bisschen
besser jetzt arbeite ich auf einem
tortendrehteller damit ich die Torte
auch schön beim Arbeiten drehen kann ihr
legt jetzt hier eine Antirutschmatte
drauf und eine ganachingplatte und dann
kommt da der erste Tortenboden drauf den
könnt ihr gerne auch noch trinken mit
etwas Aprikosenmarmelade die vorher
einfach kurz erhitzen und damit werden
dann die einzelnen Böden noch saftiger
und jetzt kommt wirklich Schicht für
Schicht immer ein bisschen Ganache
dazwischen dann wieder ein Tortenboden
wieder die nächste Schicht danach wieder
der Tortenboden und weil das ganze doch
eine relativ hohe Torte ist und Pikachu
nicht in sich zusammensacken soll kommen
da jetzt noch ein paar Holzstäbchen zum
Stabilisieren rein das heißt einfach
eine bestimmte Höhe etwa bei der Hälfte
Holzspießchen reinstecken dann eine
zweite Platte da könnt ihr gerne ein
kleines cakeboard nehmen mit 15 cm
Durchmesser oder euch auch ein bisschen
Pappe zurechtschneiden und mit Folie
überziehen mit Frischhaltefolie z.B und
das ganze damit dann stabilisieren und
dann könnt ihr weitermachen und wirklich
die Torten würden so stapeln das Pikachu
einen leichten Bauch bekommt nach oben
hin etwas kleiner wird und dann wieder
das Köpfchen drauf kommt und so kann man
die Torte am Ende gut kalt stellen die
soll jetzt wirklich gut durchkühlen
bevor ich sie dann zurechtschneide
damit ich Pikachu gut zuschneiden kann
stelle ich jetzt die Torte einfach über
Nacht kühl dann weiß ich dass sie morgen
wirklich schön fest ist zum Zuschneiden
die Torte war jetzt über Nacht im
Kühlschrank jetzt ist es schön fest und
ich kann jetzt mit Hilfe meiner
Schablone hier arbeiten das heißt ich
halte mir immer den Pikachu dahin und
schau einfach wo ich schneiden muss und
wo noch Kuchen dran muss und das mache
ich jetzt einfach mit Hilfe meiner
übrigen Ganache ich habe hier auch noch
einen Tortenboden das heißt ich kann
jetzt hier einfach schön basteln und
versuchen die Pikachu Figur so schön wie
möglich hinzubekommen das einzige was
ich auslassen werde sind die Füße und
die Hände die mache ich später dran das
heißt geht jetzt wirklich nur darum den
Kopf zu formen und den Körper zu formen
[Musik]
jetzt hat Pikachu auch ein kleines
Stupsnäschen sowie er ist eben auch hat
er oder sie ich glaube es ist
vielleicht wisst ihr das ja besser
jedenfalls kommt das Ganze zu in den
Kühlschrank die kann nach schlaf schön
fest werden in der Zwischenzeit räume
ich hier auch und welch ein Glück wir
haben sogar noch Kuchen und danach übrig
daraus werde ich später vielleicht
einfach noch ein paar Cake Pops oder so
machen ich schaue einfach mal wie mir
die Zeit reicht und dann kann ich
eigentlich schon vom Land kneten gelben
Fondant
den könnt ihr schön weich kneten damit
dass ich gut ausrollen lässt und falls
ihr da etwas Fett benötigt dann nimmt
einfach etwas Kokosöl für die Hände und
sobald er dann schön geschmeidig ist
könnt ihr ihn schön ausrollen auf Becker
Stärke
und zwar groß genug dass der komplette
Pikachu damit eingedeckt wird
[Musik]
versuche immer so schön wie möglich
auszurollen aber manchmal sind halt
Luftbläschen drin
aber das kriegen wir schon noch weg okay
jetzt kommt die Torte ich packe jetzt
auch mal die Matte hier weg
denn auf der rutscht weg und hier kann
ich die Torte schön drehen
dann mit etwas backtrennspray einsprühen
damit der Fondant drauf haftet und
einfach die Decke drüber ziehen
[Musik]
und jetzt so glatt wie möglich Pikachu
einstreichen
[Musik]
jetzt von oben nach unten schön
faltenfrei nach unten legen
und immer wieder den Fondant stretchen
und wieder anlegen das ist hier ein
bisschen schwierig gerade so am Bauch am
Hals aber ihr kriegt das schon
[Musik]
das wieder schön zusammenkneten denn
daraus werde ich noch die Arme und Beine
machen ich gehe jetzt noch weiter an
Tolga
er hat gefangen
ich vertraue dir doch
und dann kann ich hier schön alle
Feinheiten machen und ich hoffe das wird
jetzt gleich schön glatt
also dann hier noch wegschneiden und den
Rest so ein bisschen nach unten schieben
jetzt habe ich hier so ein Fondant Stück
denn jetzt bringt mir hier so ein
flacher flachstreicher glattstreicher
auch nichts deswegen nehme ich dieses
Stück von Sand und kann so ein bisschen
drüber das sieht das gleich aus wie ein
schöner glatter Pikachu
mit diesem Trick bekommst du das
Doppelkinn weg
wow ich kann jetzt in der Beauty Szene
ich mache jetzt einen neuen Laden auf
Doppelkinn weg mit der Fondant Technik
kennt das schon mal eine Ausschreibung
machen was meint passiert die Leute
anstehen
okay du kleiner Pikachu
okay das sieht brutal aus wenn ich den
Pikachu mit dem Messer an die
liebe Kinder das ist ein stumpfes
Marzipan und vom Bandmesser bitte nicht
nachmachen
[Musik]
dann kommt Pikachu jetzt erstmal kurz in
den Kühlschrank zurück
jetzt rutscht da gar nicht mal und ich
kümmere mich darum die Füße und die zwei
Hände zu modellieren
und die Äuglein
[Musik]
für die Arme und Beine habe ich jetzt
hier den Fondant mit C&C verknetet das
ist der sinnlose Pulver damit eben alle
schön aushärten kann und jetzt formt ihr
erst eine Kugel dann das ganze lang und
ich versuche dann die Form so weit es
geht ja so nach zum Modellieren das
heißt vorne etwas abflachen und nach
hinten die Pfote so ein bisschen
aufstellen und mit einem
Modellierwerkzeug dann Eindrücken
[Musik]
so ganz gefallen mir die Arme und Beine
nicht muss ich ehrlich zugeben aber ich
mache jetzt mal das Gesicht ich hoffe
das Gesicht rettet dann einfach alles
wie so oft im Leben Haare passen nicht
aber wenn das Gesicht gut geschminkt ist
dann passt auch kriegt man alles
versteckt okay
schwarz schwarzen Fondant für die Augen
erstmal gleichmäßig ausrollen und dann
kommt da der Lichtpunkt rein und ein
bisschen braun wie ich gesehen habe auf
dem Bild da ist nämlich ein bisschen
braun mit dabei was wäre Pikachu ohne
seine roten Passion deswegen kriegt er
jetzt erstmal seine Päckchen dann noch
dran ich bin dann erkennt man auch so
richtig dass es nicht wie die Pool ist
sondern pickerto
[Musik]
dein Kopf Pikachu jetzt erstmal in den
Kühlschrank und ich werde die Ohren
bemalen und das Schwänzchen
[Musik]
gedacht jetzt bin ich ja fast fertig ich
habe jetzt hier noch das Schwänzchen und
die Ohren bei den Ohren mache ich jetzt
so ich drehe die jetzt erstmal um und
bepinsele die Rückseite mir ist auch
immer wichtig doch auch hinten das
schöne ist also habe ich hier schwarze
und braune Lebensmittelfarbe und damit
wird alles bepinselt
[Musik]
Ella hatte sich eigentlich eine rise
crispy Torte gewünscht Rice Crispies und
Marshmallows den Wunsch werde ich jetzt
noch erfüllen denn ich habe mir gedacht
die Pikachu Torte alleine ist vielleicht
ein bisschen langweilig deswegen gibt's
noch einen Party gut einen essbaren ich
hoffe den kriege ich so hin wie ich
möchte denn ich habe mir gedacht ich
nehme den spritzbeutelständer so ein
bisschen als Hilfe jedenfalls brauche
ich dafür Marshmallows restgrüße und
etwas Butter die werden jetzt erstmal in
der Mikrowelle geschmolzen und ich passe
nicht nimm gleich eine große Schüssel
weiß was letztes Mal passiert ist
passiert nein
lieber die hier und ich pass auf dass
sie nicht überlaufen okay eigentlich hat
ja der spritzbeutelständer so schon die
Form
finde ich wie so ein paar die Hut aber
wenn ich da so ein pop-pong drauf packe
können es wiederum cool sein wobei das
eigentlich schon so eine Spitze hat aber
jetzt machen wir erstmal den Kegel
vielleicht baue ich das später eine
Spitze noch drauf
und jetzt kann die Butter in den
Marshmallows schmelzen und die Rest
Crispies werden so eingearbeitet
ich nehme jetzt mal eine kleine Menge
weg
für die Spitze oben da kümmere ich mich
gleich um und das ist schön
zusammenkneten das ist kompakt wird und
dann drücke ich das hier in die Form
rein
danke
und die gute Nachricht ist den
Spritzbeutel kann ich weiter verwenden
[Musik]
mittig durch durch die Spitze oben
das ist halt ein
was sagt ihr
aber sie meint so ein Partyhut ist doch
auch so der wird halt schon getragen
oder
geht doch
jetzt Roll ich Fondant aus
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach mal lila
weil Ella lila ganz gerne mag
das ganze jetzt auf 3 mm Stärke
I try my best gibt es jetzt hier einfach
so drumherum dachte ich mir
[Musik]
denken kleine
zurück
[Musik]
euer Pokémon ist halt zu schnell
ich sag's euch in dieser Torte bin die
richtige Challenge hier mit meinem Team
tut den Bubble jetzt noch ein bisschen
strukturieren ihr könnt doch einfach
eine Tüte mit trockenem Reis nehmen und
so ein bisschen dagegen drücken geht
auch gut
und dann kommt das hier drauf
Gott
was mache ich mit dem Rest hier esse ich
natürlich
ich glaube wir stellen jetzt mal die
Torte fertig
[Musik]
was macht ihr da jetzt eigentlich ähm
wir arbeiten wer arbeitet gerade
tschuldigung
wir machen eine Torte ja aber das wird
doch eine Girlande wir können doch keine
Geburtstagstorte machen ohne Geburtstag
drauf
wollen wir nicht erstmal die Torte
fertig machen nein das gehört zur Torte
das kommt dann eben der Hintergrund für
die Fotos
jetzt ist die Deko fertig ich hole die
Torte dekorierte fertig und dann kann
die Party steigen
wow das hat voll weh getan das war
mitten ins Ohr mitten ins Gesicht
oh mein Gott
die Torte ich wollte
[Musik]
wow sind Verwechseln ähnlich oder
jetzt
und das schwänzle einfach hinten hin ja
ja
jetzt kannst du kommen deine Torte ist
fertig
und
es fehlst du denn dein Pikachu
du kannst auch draufsetzen das kann ich
gleich machen wir können Sie jetzt kurz
hier lassen und gleich setze ich dir
dann drauf okay und weißt du was da drin
ist im Hut Preis
und
du bist ein richtiger Pikachu Fan gell
glaubst du mit dieser Torte wird deine
Party richtig cool
ja
freust du dich schon
okay dann würde ich jetzt nämlich sagen
die Torte wird heute natürlich jetzt
nicht angeschnitten das machen wir wenn
deine Freunde da sind oder wenn wir dann
Geburtstag feiern und dann nehmen wir
euch noch ein bisschen mit zeigen euch
noch ein paar Eindrücke von der Party
also Ella dann gehen wir jetzt zur Party
oder nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]